peace be with you welcome to the dean
charm eddie your host if you have not
subscribed subscribe
right now and get ready for another
exciting show we know that islamophobia
is rampant now why we're going to be
discussing that and there's that all up
in your face islamophobia then there's
that subtle
islamophobia that's what we're going to
be talking about today give me some
examples
here on the dean show and then
after the rain comes the sunshine we're
going to give some good news so you're
not all gloomy because a lot of times
you hear the sad news
you're like why are they talking bad
about us when we're just peace-loving
people trying to have a peaceful
relationship with our neighbors
and we're so misunderstood so if my next
guest secretary general
is not here on the dean's show be right
back don't go anywhere
[Music]
this is the theme show
[Music]
thank you for having me on thank you for
being on the dean's show it's my
pleasure it is my pleasure sir now
uh i had opened up the show and i had
talked about the
you know you're on the ground you see
like this growing islamophobia is this
uh
something that you're also experiencing
you're being a part of isn't you guys
are out there doing a lot of community
work and
um interfaith you know different
dialogues with different people of other
religions how is it on the ground what
you're seeing now
absolutely you know it does on the front
lines of working with the community
working on interfaith and so on and
recent polls have shown
uh and our experience has shown that
public perception of islam is at an
all-time low right now
unfortunately that's a fact that's a
fact right um
it was okay for a while but now it's
getting worse again
and we are up against such a machine
that is constantly vilifying muslims and
lying about islam
and they have a vested interest in
making us out to be the bad guy
you know we're doing what we can we're
doing what we can but we need to
double our efforts now we talked about
this all up in your face
islamophobia bill maher saying that you
know the 1.6
billion muslims are like the mafia
comparing muslims to
you know like um the nazis doing some
crazy just
open-your-face stuff you know what i
mean um but what about this now there's
a recent article with larry king
yeah talking about the more subtle
approach
sure that's a very important distinction
so you've got the in your face
islamophobia like you said which is a
problem obviously
but it's a less dangerous problem
because we all recognize it as
islamophobia we all recognize it as a
form of racism
somebody obviously just doesn't like you
somebody has misconceptions
about you but we can recognize it for
what it is
the more devious problem
in my opinion is this more subtle form
of islamophobia
where there's a very subtle form of
racism very subtle form of stereotype
that isn't immediately apparent the
problem is
the person doing it may not be even
aware of what they're saying so for
example there was a recent um
incident with larry king where a
gentleman wanted to take
his picture with with mr king turns out
that this fellow was from saudi arabia
who wanted to take
the um the picture and so larry king
said something along the lines of
oh i'm a jew is it okay for a saudi to
take a picture with
with a jew and he said of course yes we
have many followers inside rabe and so
on
so he took the picture with with mr king
and he smiled and so on that afterwards
larry king
says to this muslim from saudi arabia he
says now go fight isis.
[Music]
on the surface it might seem okay he was
making a joke about muslims and jews and
then fighting isis and so on
but underneath it right is this very
subtle insinuation that muslims don't
like jews
right which is which is which is not
true we see them as
people of the book we have some issues
with
with israeli policy towards palestinians
but we have nothing against jews
as as a religion and then something
along the lines of now go fight isis
well what what do american muslims have
to do with isis what does saudi arabia
have to exactly yeah
with isis right so that would for
example that would that would be like me
uh saying to an american christian
go fight andres brevik in europe you
remember the uh
uh the shooter in europe i believe it
was uh
he killed some norway right it was at a
camp and he killed about 70 muslims many
of them were children
this fellow was a devout christian and
that would be like me saying to a
christian here now go fight
andres breivik or me telling a christian
here now go fight the skinheads
in europe right what do they have to do
with
the radicals in europe why am i holding
american christians accountable for the
radicals in europe
similarly why is larry king holding
a saudi or an american liable for
the crazies in the middle east and
throughout the world right so it's
it's this double standard but on the
surface
that's not how it may come off right
he's just concerned about what's going
on in the middle east and he's telling
us to go fight isis
i want to take you to this clip right
now so you can see it
and then get your comments on it sure at
the kokomo islamic center
it's time that we put all of these
pieces of crap on notice that
we're not taking their school yeah um
that's that's the first drawing on our
uh little uh uh artist contest
we're here
[Laughter]
okay so you got to see this clip it's
very it's very sad seeing this stuff so
we're gonna we're gonna go to break and
then we're gonna get your comments on
this is this uh this one which would
this
fit in uh this is the very obvious this
is the very overt islamophobia okay so
we'll be right back more to discuss this
clip
here on the dean's show don't go
anywhere bismillah
people wonder what is the status of
jesus peace be upon him
in islam do muslims respect him
do they honor him is he a prophet or is
he god
according to islam first
all muslims consider jesus peace be upon
him as a muslim
do you know that the word muslim mean
the one who submit to god's will
to muslims the word muslim is an
honorary title
to those who completely surrender
themselves to god's will
for instance in the quran surah 37
103 allah says
in translation when abraham and ishmael
completely surrendered themselves and
they became muslim
and they followed the orders of god on
the sacrifice
so therefore it was an honorary title
for abraham to be called a muslim
when he completely surrendered himself
to god's will
do you know that according to muslims
all prophets of god
were muslims and all of them carried the
same message
in which they were calling people to
submit to god's will
according to islam god has sent
approximately about 124 000
prophets to this world in the quran
god have mentioned only 25 of all of
these prophets
and out of those 25 prophets god have
chose
five to be called the best prophets
on only one prophet of those five
prophets
god have called him the messiah which
was
jesus peace be upon him do you know
that a muslim cannot say the word jesus
by itself
and he have to say peace be upon him as
a form of respect
do you know that muslims cannot and will
not represent
an image of jesus peace be upon him
because no one can replace his image
again this is the way we honor jesus
peace be upon him how many time have you
seen
jesus beast upon him being represented
in a cartoon or an
image in any muslim country you will
never
why because this is considered to be a
great disrespect and actually it's a
blasphemy according to muslims
to represent jesus peace be upon him in
a form of an image
in the contrary you will see this being
done so many times in the west
did you know that part of being a muslim
that we have to believe in jesus peace
be upon him
and a muslim is not a muslim he does not
believe in jesus
do you know that god have mentioned
jesus peace be upon him in the quran 25
times
verses he only mentioned mohammed bisbee
only five times
do you know that the most honorable
woman in islam was mary the mother of
jesus peace be upon him
do you know that mary was mentioned in
the bible only 18 times
and in the quran she was mentioned 32
times
almost 100 percent more
do you know that in the quran god have
dedicated a whole chapter
for the mother of jesus surat maryam or
chapter of mary
also do you know that god have dedicated
a whole chapter in the quran
to talk about the last supper
do you know that the most number of
people
named jesus worldwide were muslims
this is jesus peace be upon him in islam
we honor him
we respect him he is our role model
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the dean's show secretary
general from istna has him
yes thank you sir thank you okay so we
got to see this clip and it's i
obviously it's very sad you know you you
go into your
house of worship you want to worship the
same god that jesus worship the creator
of the heavens and the earth you're
going there minding your business
yeah and then you see these people
waving this confederate flag
you know with uh many of them armed yeah
and it's a scary
feeling what were your thoughts on this
a few things first we have to remember
to remain calm
right no situation ever got better
because people
lost their tempers so we always need to
stay calm second
rasulullah and the sahaba and every
prophet
went through the exact same thing you
had people that opposed them people that
gave them a hard time
and they dealt with much worse than this
third thing is this is a teaching
opportunity
right we have to view these
protests and islamophobes as people who
are misguided
and do what we can to guide them we have
to remember the story of umar
ibn khattab who became the second
khalifa of islam
he was one of the most
violent and one of the most rebellious
people against islam
but even he converted at some point so
you never know
who allah chooses to guide so people
like this either
engage them politely in a nice way
teach them about our religion invite
them in
break some bread with them try to
explain to them that we have nothing to
do with what's going on overseas
in fact many of us came here to escape
what was going on overseas
our religion is a religion of peace our
religion is one that respects
christianity and judaism
and try to open their hearts to islam
not necessarily even to convert them but
just to get them to stop hating us
and if they're receptive alhamdulillah
if not then we've done our part
we've done our part in explaining our
side and distancing ourselves from
what's going on overseas
if he chooses to hold on to his hatred
and his prejudices
it's on him at that point i like what
you what you're saying we take something
really gloomy and dark
yeah which is obviously you know what
we're seeing here people basically
mocking
you know uh someone who we love mocking
the the way of life that we practice
when in actuality now turning into
something good you said call them in
why are you standing outside maybe in
the cold yeah absolutely
come inside and break some bread do you
remember in arizona
a valley man who went to a rally outside
a phoenix mosque on friday to protest
islam has a change of heart somewhat
went to the event where armed
demonstrators spoke out against the
muslim faith
but after being invited inside the
mosque he says the congregation
made him feel welcome here's jason
ledger and the organizer of friday's
rally wearing the profanity lace
t-shirts
now things have changed out of respect
for the islamic people knowing what i
know
now since i have talked to them and
spoke with them no no i would not do
that again
um just because i don't want to offend
or hurt those people
where they had the bikers and yeah there
were hundreds of bikers they were
protesting at a measured i think
it was in phoenix phoenix arizona in
phoenix arizona
and then what what did they do the
people at this masjid were
were very wise mesh allah they invited
the leaders
of this of uh of the organizers right
they invited them into the masjid and
they explained to them
uh that we have nothing to do with
what's going on overseas they broke
bread with them they had a meal with
them
and then by the end of it all you see
them hugging he had a change of heart he
had a complete change of heart he had a
complete change of heart mesha allah
so this was somebody who was very angry
he was he was armed he had hundreds of
bikers with him
he he organized a protest against a
masjid
and within just a few hours right of
this very calm
peaceful accommodating response
you saw them shaking hands and hugging
right that is the example for us to
follow
i heard a recently a beautiful quote by
nelson mandela who talked about no one
is born
with this hate they're taught to hate
absolutely teach them how to love now
absolutely we got to read those let's go
to we're going to go back to another
gloomy situation
okay okay a little scary absolutely and
we want to bring some light on it
after the rain comes the sunshine like
we just did let's see we're going to go
to this clip right now
holland is being sued over declaring his
store a muslim free zone
which he made while standing in front of
the confederate battle in bloom
okay we got to just see this clip now
you know at one point the
african-americans in this country were
being told to get to the back of the bus
yeah there was black free zones actually
yeah is this in america we're seeing now
muslim-free zones
subhanallah these are the times that we
live in and
again you were talking about taking a
negative and making into a positive
after the rain there is the sunshine
absolutely yes this is actually a good
sign
right because whenever a minority
receives a lot of pushback means that
they're on the verge of becoming
mainstream
right so if you look back in american
history jews went through the same thing
catholics german irish
chinese african americans obviously you
name it
right they all had to go through their
phase of being discriminated against
being hated but then eventually that's a
sign that you're becoming very close
to reaching mainstream so that's that's
the positive that we can
we can take from this and again this
this gentleman who is who is doing this
it's a teaching moment we need to reach
out to him which i know hassan shibli
the director of care of florida
did reach out to him and they were
making some progress for a time but then
things fell apart unfortunately but this
is a sign that muslims
were becoming mainstream now if you put
a muslim free zone most people
once you open up the door of
communication you realize what a muslim
is and you realize that
that jesus peace be upon him you know he
would uh probably be more your
complexion
yeah and he would look more like a
muslim looks like today
yeah some people are seeing some
pictures that because you know people
have modified it we don't actually know
exactly what it looks like but people
you know they give some descriptions
he would actually uh probably not be
admitted into the store either yeah
that's true that's true and and the
thing is here's
he would deny jesus we have to
sympathize somewhat with this store
owner because i
i see him as a victim yes of all this
propaganda that you have
in the medium in in the media you know
you mentioned earlier that
um hate is not natural
hate is taught so is fear
i don't think fear is natural i think
fear is taught
and this man has been taught to fear
muslims he's been taught by the media
he's been taught by islamophobes
he's been taught by a very well
organized well-funded
islamophobia machine so now it's the
responsibility of
the eddie show the dean show it's the
responsibility of isna
and ikna and care and all the other
muslim organizations
to counter that and this is you know
this is why allah sent us here
i love it i love that's what our our way
of life this way of life
that calls us to have peace with our
creator peace with ourselves peace with
humanity
to be optimistic yeah to take these
gloomy situations
absolutely and make the best a very
optimistic grandson absolutely
not to just look at ourselves like the
victims but to
put this information out there and to
see how we can diagnosis because many
muslims will see this and they'll fall
into great despair they'll be really
saddened
yeah you know to think that okay this is
what my neighbor thinks some
thinks of me you know and um hopefully
they can
go ahead and and listen to this
wonderful advice that you're seeing and
describe the situation no but you're
right we cannot have a defeatist
mentality yeah
the early muslims they were always
outnumbered they were always
outnumbered but they were very positive
and they were successful
so we need to get out of this mentality
of we are victims we are oppressed
we have some issues that we're dealing
with and we're doing what we can as a
community
but we have to remain optimistic and
situations like this
we need to see them as opportunities to
represent ourselves
see them as opportunities to talk to
people about islam and correct people's
misconceptions
opportunities that's what we have here
and we'll be right back with more on the
dean's show don't go anywhere
being an african-american being a
veteran of the united states military
i feel as though these people who came
out here armed outside of
the mosque a place of worship is
completely disrespectful
this is on u.s soil they're us citizens
they have the right freedom of speech
freedom of spirituality
and i think that is disgraceful this is
not the american way this is not the
american dream
is there a purpose to our lives
do we simply exist to make a living
or were we meant for something greater
something more meaningful
i looked everywhere for answers
and i found islam
[Music]
i started my journey
[Music]
have you started yours
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the dean show now what
would you how would you approach someone
you're
going to your house of worship and you
see
or you're you're going to the store and
you see a sign
muslim free zone how would you engage
with someone like this on the other side
yeah first thing again you have to be
very calm
very polite and you have to know when to
engage that person you know do you want
to engage them at the busiest time
of the day when they have customers
going in and out and so forth probably
not
right we have to be tactful so maybe
wait until the shop owners
he closes shop maybe call them after
hours
ask them to to come meet with them right
at a convenient time for them
then you engage them maybe you invite
them over to the masjid maybe you invite
them over to your house
right because the measured might be
intimidating for them if you invite them
over to your house invite them over
for dinner who's going to say no to a
free dinner right you invite them into
your home and you break bread
together it says something and that's
that's what they're not expecting
what they're expecting is a sort of uh
violent or antagonistic
response right they're trying to get a
rise out of us
but let's be tactful right and respond
with kindness and generosity
i think inviting people over for dinner
at your home is a great way to start
and this is what what islam teaches us
yes so it's not something that we're
doing covert this is what our religion
teaches us this is
the basics of islam uh but a lot of
times you know muslims they
might react and it's beautiful you're
given that advice not to react on
emotion
yeah and just to stay calm and another
thing is to really learn your religion
and you'll see how to communicate with
people in a positive light and
be optimistic and take these situations
to hopefully do some good with it
absolutely you you have to be armed with
knowledge knowledge yeah right this is
not an easy thing to do
interacting with people that are afraid
of muslims or are very antagonistic
towards muslims
is not an easy thing to do so you have
to arm yourself with the right knowledge
not only about islam but about modern
issues
statistics on terrorism and things of
that nature and are muslims really
involved in these kinds of things and
right you have to know what to say you
have to anticipate the questions that
they're going to ask
you have to anticipate how they're going
to respond you have to anticipate
the biases that they might have and what
they heard on a certain news channel or
from a certain
islamophobe so that you know how to
counter them because if you can't
counter them properly
you might just end up reinforcing the
negative concepts that they have and in
the verbatim word of god the quran
god almighty is actually talking about
this not to return harshness of
harshness but with good and then this
person might end up being
absolutely no situation ever got worse
because somebody was calm
and polite and loving yeah absolutely
now tell us
how do you how does uh your organization
that you're the secretary general
of do you invite uh people of other
faiths
christians and other not yet muslims who
are out there to get to learn about
the muslims in islam absolutely isn't we
are engaged in
interfaith work 24 7. right we do this
year round
and interfaith work is one of those
things that unfortunately is
is undervalued by many people within our
community they just don't see
the value in it interfaith work is
building relationships
it's building friendships it's building
partnerships that result
in collaboration some of our best
supporters people who have defended
muslims have been people of other faiths
christians and jews and otherwise
in churches in synagogues and in the
halls of congress right
but those people defended us one because
out of
out of their goodwill but also because
of the relationships that they have
with muslims right muslims are a
minority
in america we are about one percent that
is a tiny tiny tiny
minority it makes sense for us to
partner
with larger groups who share our values
right why why wouldn't we do it and this
is this is one of the best forms of
dawah
they they they see us they get to know
us they know that islam is really just
an extension
of their own religion this is not a new
religion this is not this is not an
other we are not people to be feared we
are your fellow
americans we are your brothers and
sisters in humanity
we are your brothers and sisters in
monotheism and we
have the same concerns and the same
aspirations as you do
i've got a mortgage to pay i got to get
my kids through college
i'm worried about losing my job i have a
fight with my wife or whatever the
situation may be right
i'm going through the exact same things
that you are there's no need for you to
hate me or to fear me
now for the night yet muslims are
brothers in humanity who are out there
and they're watching
they got uh they don't have no plans uh
next weekend
yeah you're actually hosting an event
coming up i have a suggestion
we have our annual convention every year
it is one of the largest
gatherings of muslims in north america
15 to 20 000 people come
every year it is labor day weekend in
chicago at the rosemont convention
center
september 4th through september 7th
everyone is invited this is not just for
muslims this is for people of any faith
or people of no faith we have scholars
we have
activists we have entertainment we have
events for the youth we have events for
college-age people we have
um round table workshops we have a
little bit of everything and we have
something for everyone donald trump can
come
all the politicians donald trump is
welcome to come yes
yes if he wants george zimmerman uh this
guy from the muslim free zone
they're all over he should he should
come and see muslim families with little
kids
you know running around just coming to
learn about their religion
they should come and hear how
beautifully we speak
about christianity and judaism about how
beautifully we speak about
our country america about how
beautifully we speak
about al-kitab people of the book our
christian jewish brothers and sisters
and the guys in indiana standing with
these masks that we saw the video by
themselves and they are welcome
everybody is welcome to come and this is
not just isn't this convention right
this is chicago's convention the chicago
muslim community
they're hosting us they are partners in
this event the council of islamic
organizations of greater chicago
they are our co-hosts so this is not
just an island event this is a chicago
event
thank you we started with peace we are
with peace thank you so much thank you
so much thank you thank you for having
me very much
and thank you for taking the time to
tune in to the dean show
again if you haven't subscribed
subscribe and we took
the all up in your face islamophobia
talked about it a little bit and then
the subtle islamophobia
and then took the gloomy turned it into
something bright
we need to be optimistic we need to be
educated and if you care you need to
share with your
best example that islam teaches us to be
upon
and go ahead and inviting those of your
neighbors
to have a good communication with
yourself so we can go ahead
and try to clear up this misinformation
about islam and muslims
we hope that you got to benefit from
this week's episode of the dean show and
we look forward to
seeing you next time and maybe we'll see
you at the convention
make sure you're there we'll see you
peace be with you so i'm like
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
you